chuckle echo tough vs. smart so wait
what is this do you think is this like
is it better to be tough than smart or
just in general okay well you just read
the question as it was stated it just
said topic for podcasts tough vs smart
in my opinion I don't think you need to
be tough versus smarter I don't think it
needs to be tough or smart I think you
need to be tough and smart I don't think
those two traits are mutually exclusive
at all and being tough and being smart
is actually what we want we you know so
when we think of tough I think we think
of using friends using blunt force to
solve a problem right and and you might
think that using blunt force to solve a
problem is stupid and at the same time
you might think that's stepping back
from a problem and taking a look or
stepping back away from it might be
giving up so you're weak or you're not
tough but there are times when those
options are the best options there's
some times when blunt force is the best
option and you just gotta power through
and you gotta be tough and you got to
get over the hurdle or over the obstacle
or through the obstacle through blunt
force trauma and there's other times
where the best possible thing you could
do is step back and quit beating your
head against the wall and trying to
blunt force through something you want
to step back and find another way you
want to be smarter not harder
and I think the ginn this comes out to
balance and people pushing when it's a
good time to push and a good time to be
tough and at the same time knowing that
you need to balance that with being
smart and the only way you're gonna be
able to do that the only way you're
gonna be able to figure out if you're
just being too smart or not smart enough
or too tough or not tough enough
is to be able to detach and step back
and look and see assess the situation if
you get to in the weeds on it you won't
be able to see that a you've beat your
head against the wall 47 times that's
enough stop step back and find another
way just like if you're so engrossed in
solving the problem in finding the
perfect solution and finding the least
impact wave through the smartest
resolution you don't if you don't step
back from that you might not see that if
you wait any longer on your brilliant
plan yeah you're gonna be overrun by
their problem itself so being smart and
being tough are not mutually exclusive
you need to be both and the way that you
balance them is by stepping back
detaching and doing always doing an
assessment of what's happening so what
if you had to choose and I'm gonna make
the question even harder
no specific scenario what if you had to
choose you got to be either really smart
but not tough or really smart or really
tough not smart what youth unfortunately
you have to go with being smarter yeah
it's not unfortunate but this is the the
the reality is being smarter is better
yes because being smarter means you can
find another solution
but you know the the wall that you might
be banging your head against might
literally be impassable through that
through that section you know and if all
you're gonna do is beat your head
against it eventually you're gonna
you're gonna not make and you're gonna
die yeah so being smart is always better
yeah and hey I guess I should add it
just in life let's say you know but
really the question I was wondering is
like in life you know God was there and
he said okay I'm gonna be still one of
these on you interest in your life you
can either have a knack for being really
smart but but not tough at all or really
tough and abused by smart because it I
shouldn't even be like making this like
this is a hard decision being smarter is
better yeah is being smarter is better
if this is there's no doubt about it
that's being smarter is better but get
by the way being smarter look
the human race why do we rule the world
over the animals I mean you tell me that
you're tougher than a chick than a
chimpanzee
well me Yeah right the only reason the
the thing that wins is intellect and
it'll win every single time well it'll
win a lot of the time a lot of the time
and if you're smart you can figure out a
way to overcome the toughness tough yeah
and not even altameyer our bodies yeah
exactly right exactly right like when
you say are you - am i tougher than a
gorilla we'll say well in a way yeah you
know I find a shotgun would ya or if I
have a yeah anything you know anything
that I think up to build or buy you know
because of other people like me thought
it up and I use their knowledge you know
cuz I'm smart to do it which goes back
to the original question or what
question we asked for a while ago about
college like go to college and improve
your smartness get smarter you know yeah
that's why I always say that on the
podcast I'm not man I'm not always
talking about being stronger and faster
and bigger and tougher I'm always
talking about you got to be smarter too
no doubt about it
didn't the success I've had from my life
is zero of it just about zero but has
come from anything physical or being
tough now there is a mental toughness
that does help you when you are doing
intellectual things well I mean I can
force myself to do some intellectual
goals or some intellectual challenges
that if I wasn't if I didn't and
toughest in the best word but if it
wasn't mentally tough I won't be able to
do it right yeah but if you're smart
you're smart figure out ways to get
mentally tough like you're like hey I'm
like I know I'm not mentally tough I'm
smart enough to know I'm not mentally
tough where I'm enough is it yeah let me
figure out a way to get met I'll figure
out a good workout would you rather be
the guy that is really tough and can
stay in cold water for 45 minutes or the
guy that invents a wetsuit like Jack
O'Neill and I can stay in the water for
unlimited amount of time now there you
go case in point Jack O'Neill keeping it
real